all right I don't usually do this but
I'm gonna click 10 minute game just in
the lobby this could very well be a one
game stream because I have things to do
and really I'm just taking a break
does anyone want to play
what's my rapid rating oh I guess we'll
find out
Oh 2389 okay so let's try and take this
slightly seriously I'm going to play an
English opening I did a stream yesterday
where I was taking opening requests I
know there are a few people that wanted
to see in English but I didn't play the
English yesterday and now I'm running
into a Dutch yeah Dutch is playable I'm
gonna start with Knight f3 and I might
actually transpose into what I normally
play against the Dutch which is a
version of the London I'll play d4 here
apologies for my dog in the background I
don't know if it's audible and now I'll
play Bishop f4 an idea actually had a
game yesterday in the Dutch two where I
was playing the black side of this but
the idea here is to play an early c5 and
to try and undermine this d6 pawn c6 is
a bit weird
usually people castle thanks Mustique
you for subbing I'm considering playing
this right away takes takes that's okay
for white and it's bits from sarony Leo
always good to see you Sarah knew Leo if
black takes I might consider not even
taking back and sacking upon so black
castles I have a few moves Queen b3 and
Bishop 2
for trying to provoke d5 and then have
the e5 square I think I'll start with
Bishop c4 because if we got some
structure like this the center kind of
closes down whoa it's more bits from
coward Kong yeah the center is now
closed the block has given up the e5
square usually the plan in the Dutch is
to play e5 but now that's pretty much
impossible I'm gonna start with h4 here
znation chess seventeen months in a row
I'm here leader are you calling me your
leader I don't know if I lean it that
much but thanks for subbing well I play
each four I'm probably not gonna Castle
I want my rook to stay on each one I
could play 95 right away
that looks very nice attacking g6
there's also an idea to play h5 and if
g5 takes takes and then h6 let's play 95
just simple simpler to understand King
h7 you've been considering g4 here looks
like I can maybe start having some fun
also considering something like this
there's actually a funny line in looking
at Queen c2 Knight bt7
Knight takes g6 takes g6 takes f5 King
f7 Bishop g6 King e6 and then mates that
was just a natural line to calculate
because this is one of the most natural
moves but I think I take g6 is just
crushing there my dog is so excited can
people hear my dog and hello to people
in the chats okay so he's not going into
that line that's probably another move I
could still consider g4 Johanna tries in
the chat and the ice in the chat okay
let's stay focused g4 takes takes
and then I'm finding my way to attack
this like h5 coming I don't think I need
this Bishop if black ever takes and he
loses his main defender so let's play g4
I played the Grob opening yesterday I
was like a premature g4g 4 can sometimes
be a right or a good move you have to
play it at the right time so I'm
actually expecting this because I don't
see what else black does but there's
still looming ideas of h5 and black is
completely underdeveloped on the Queen
side so e 6 that's a move I mean do I
just play h5 because now the the King
side is guaranteed to open up just with
a pawn tension my black would love to
somehow close things down but it's just
not possible so takes I could throw in
this move Intermezzo let's do that then
I'll probably take back with that pawn
and then this this pawn will be pinned
and I'm ready to Castle queenside put a
rook on G 1 lady H files half open and
the g5 will open soon black is
preventing me from castling which is
slightly annoying
oh you don't hear the dog maybe I'm the
only one who hears a dog my mic is good
at doing the cardioid pattern it's gotta
be a lot of squirrels outside or the
mailman okay
Oh some people hear the dog okay I have
to focus what to do Queen g5 I mean the
pawns attacks but I don't know if black
wants to take it there's some
interesting line rook h5 Queen takes and
then this probably not worth playing
because Queen g1 in the end I could play
this just migrate the night towards the
Kings side if Queen takes I ripped g1
I'm also finding f4 let's play 92 the
queen is not always the best defender
because it's a strongest piece so if I
attack it it's vulnerable
I could play off four right away I could
play a three I mean why not f4 right
away Knight d4 I'll win material you
like the doge my dog is in the
background I have a dog command now it's
not the most informative command but it
is a command there is something to be
said for like training and situations
with like distracting like some
distracting environment to learn how to
focus when when there's distractions so
I could take on that five
I mean 93 I could play a three there's a
lot of options here looking at the
forcing lines first Knight c3 Knight
before queen h2
wait no that loses t3 with Chuck I think
I'll just play a three
I mean I'm keeping all the tension I'm
preventing locks only source of counter
play so I think things are okay just
AdBlue saying hey dad again
if I'm your dad does that make Nakamura
your grandpa whoa whoa it's $50 Congrats
on 10k followers from Kover yet another
distraction okay I I have to focus but
thank you so much Kover uh takes takes I
mean there's so many nice-looking moves
let's start with taking the G file open
I'll Castle queenside and a lot of these
moves I can just kind of play
intuitively if Nakamura is your grandpa
and I'm your dad then Eric Hanson would
be your uncle right too confusing all
right
rook DG 1 is coming teenage 793 I mean
there's so much pressure let's do it and
black will be very much tied down to f5
there's so many ideas here like 93 9 h5
906 there's Queen h2 and just complete
destruction there's ideas of rook takes
h6 followed by Queen h2 which might be
some force made threat like peace
harmony
this Knight is left behind
so my time management hasn't been the
best my focus hasn't been the best but
my position is pretty good and again
thank you so much cover to figure out
what to spend this money on let me also
chat if you're randomly and given $50
what you spend it towards is this force
mate takes takes Queen h2 King g7 Knight
f5 King here and then Queen h5 is mate
right I'm not missing anything I don't
think takes takes king g6 is the same
thing kingi Sixers actually a more
beautiful checkmate
I guess Black has options here to run
but he can't hide half a meal in Norway
every day I'm so great grateful I don't
live in Berlin
Nile Homer 1,400 bits wait a minute
I can also take nah that's too
complicated let's just meet this is like
made in two or three no more than three
could you play a time on of or news o
BOGO or the English with III I played
the English this game I played the
English specifically because I was
getting the request yesterday maybe I'll
go back in time and just show what
happened to this game
so there's two legal moves for lack this
is any fancy roommate this is maiden -
this was only a legal move and then
Quidditch I was mates that was a nice
fun game oh yeah we can go to analysis
board was able to use like some bit of
opening preparation we got to this kind
of nice middle game that will probably
go on YouTube do I end the YouTube video
here or you I include the analysis I
might end it here but I might not if I
end up here thanks YouTube people for
watching
okay yeah well I said I was probably
gonna cut the video on YouTube
I'm definitely cutting it there cuz
don't want you to people to just
continually wait for the analysis or
maybe I'll make a cut and then just show
the analysis but let's look at what
happens at 5:00 it's wouldn't what is
this the most it's has to me within the
top like 10 most popular responses most
popular is usually this or this or this
these are probably the three most
popular ie6 is a move I play g6 also
playable d6 playable b6 playable I think
all of these moves come before f5 can
check in the database masters at let's
start with masters so now sexy 5e 65 G
66 Oh F 5 ok so it does exist b6 and d6
are a bit less popular what about on me
chests I don't think my dog has stopped
barking like this whole time I deeply
apologize maybe I'll try and like bring
him here people want to see the dog ok
let's go forward with the game first so
the line I chose its offbeat but I think
it's very reputable and it's very
playable oh I shouldn't show people the
dog because some people might be
allergic have to be considerate of
allergic people so g6 III yeah so we
reached like the normal kind of position
usually black castles here as like I'm
not even lying like to over 2000 games
of castling everything else is pretty
rare after castling c5 is a move I'm
pretty sure this is computer approved
I think yeah like stock fish gives some
small edge and if anyone doesn't know
what to play against the Dutch and you
play English or Queens pawn or London
it's definitely something to look into
further whole idea here is why it opens
up this diagonal and very often provokes
d5 which is what happened in this game
so wait this is not my game oh this is a
stock fish line
okay let's mute stock fish at least for
the time being and I'll just show what
happened yeah this is a nice
transformation after d5 Bishop d3 then
the play flowed very nicely and black
was a little bit slow to develop when I
played Queen c2 I was really hoping for
this line like be d7 and then Knight
takes g6 and I believe oh did I miss
calculates wait a minute I think I
miscalculated what was i calculating
oh maybe I just didn't see I thought the
king would have to go to e6 but it could
go to g8 so I could have blundered it's
not really what I was calculating maybe
it was anyway my opponent didn't go for
that and then then it was so much fun
and everything kind of worked out okay
I'll try and find my dog I'll be right
back in the meantime I'll leave people
with the puzzle of the day puzzle of the
day black to move good luck try and
solve it before I get back